the jurogan experience but it's like
usa is one of very few countries that
competes clean
and so it's like how do you compete you
know yeah uh
so he had this outside pressure of to
like
produce an athlete whether it was the
right way or wrong way isn't that [ __ ]
up
that statement that you just said but i
know it to be true when you said the usa
is one of the few countries that
competes clean
that's it's actually true oh it's and so
strange
i remember at the junior worlds that i
competed that the winning guy in my
weight class
snatched more than what i clean a jerked
like this like 18 year old kid and he
like power snatched 155 kilos
it was where is it from i want to say he
was
like somewhere over in europe and i'm
pretty sure it was like the whole podium
got popped
it's kind of like i remember like the
2008 olympics like the 94 kilo class
they started testing down
and it's like like currently it's like
ninth place guy has the bronze medal
because they just kept testing down down
down so did they pop them right after
the competition do they pop them
i think it's like a few years later
because it's like at the time with the
drug they don't know how to test for
right and so they save the samples and
then years later they figure out how to
test for this stuff
did you see icarus i i watched like the
first bit of it
uh yeah i haven't seen the whole thing
yet it's [ __ ] nuts
yeah it's nuts i mean it's just crazy
like if there's a sport with money
people are going to start bringing drugs
into it well the the crazy thing about
that was it was a russian state sponsor
they sponsored the entire dope they
they doped everyone that guy uh gregory
uh rachenkoff
yeah the guy who is the supposed
anti-doping guy from russia he said the
only people they didn't dope
were the figure skaters because uh they
they found that the figure skating
it actually interfered with uh fine
motor skills
really yeah so making the women too
manly so kind of funny about that
my parents were both figure skaters whoa
and so they they're both olympians 1976
like
no [ __ ] yeah paris freestyle and my dad
talks about like he would be in the
locker room
and like different countries they he was
like they just had their syringes on the
on the bench oh my god and he was like
you'd come in after your
session on the ice and he's like the
german team's just there like
like they're not even hiding it because
it was legal well they didn't test
yeah they didn't know right you know but
the american team did that too back then
supposedly
oh really yeah i was reading this thing
about bruce jenner where they were
talking about
all the [ __ ] that they gave him when he
was winning the decathlon and then they
gave
[ __ ] to every apparently post
when it was uh post the the uh
eastern europeans winning like a lot of
weightlifting competitions and then
it was clear that they were experience
experimenting with
different kinds i remember reading the
article
uh like they were testing it at york
barbell
and like i remember reading these
journal entries from the lifters and
some
uh they they were bolting the bars
like to the ground or to squat racks and
they would
take the drugs and then just push on the
bars as hard as they can
because their theory was like the
heaviest bar you can lift is the one you
cannot
and it was like huh what and some of
these lifters
are saying like yo these pills or these
injections
are where everything is coming from like
this is where all my gains are coming
from and then others were like no no
it's the training methodology like the
drugs have nothing to do with it i'm
just hitting all these personal records
um yeah maybe a little bit of both
i think i think i know which one which
one's helping out for
sure but i mean you know you don't just
taking the drugs doesn't make you
stronger you have to actually
lift the weights yeah for sure the drugs
are helping like this
the idea that the drugs don't help i've
actually seen someone argue that before
oh i that steroids are useless and if
you train properly they actually get in
the way i was like
what are you talking about what are you
talking yeah i mean there's been a
couple people that
like in crossfit that got popped and
they're like oh the drugs weren't even
doing anything and it's like oh silly
boy
of course they were yeah they work
there's a reason why they're so
prevalent and there's a reason why they
test for them yeah they don't test for
things that don't work they're not
testing you for cheerios
you know they're just to test you for
[ __ ] that really works i mean like the
one guy
the one guy that he was on the podium at
the games and then got popped
i competed against him a month like six
or eight months prior
and like the the one stat like he was
snatching like 260 or 265
and then he shows up to the games and
snatches like 290 and he's taking he
almost hit 300
and he's like no the drugs had nothing
to do with it it's like
i bet they did yeah i don't believe that
it's like like you've been in the sport
for years
like if you're just a beginner you can
make progress like that but i'm like
you've been in the sport for years
yeah and then in the last six months you
just had this huge spike in your
performance and you're like oh no it's
just because i became dedicated it's
like
i'm not buying it dedication yeah it's
so important to be dedicated
now how often do they test everybody i
mean pretty often
do they show up randomly yeah yeah so we
have out of competition drug testing
um you know it's like when i did weight
lifting we
we're on like the nan program so no
advance notice so you had to give
if you're in the olympic sports you're
tested by the olympic association
you have to give one hour a day of where
you are
and they show up they don't call nothing
so like everyone put from like five to
six a.m i'll be in my dorm room
and like if you're leaving for the
airport at like 4 50
you'll see someone sitting outside the
dorm just like looking at their watch
waiting for 5am to hit and give the
knock
and like they'll follow you they come
with you to school work
doesn't matter what you're doing will
they make you miss a flight
uh yeah probably i'd assume they would
but i mean like i remember having to
talk to professors of like i have an
exam and like i didn't have to
pee so i'm like you guys got to come to
class with me
and having to like explain to a
professor of like hey like these guys
are here for drug testing i compete in
the sport
is it okay if they just sit there and
wow
yeah so the crosstalk is creepy i mean
it's weird like i've had it before where
they showed up at 5 a.m i didn't have to
pee and i'm like yo
it's 5 a.m i'm going back to bed and
they're
they're like yep we'll sit right here so
you sit in the room while you're
sleeping yeah they just pull up a chair
and they'll just sit there
just stare at you go back to bed how can
you sleep while this guy
just like put on the tv or something for
him and like you just go back to bed
i mean after a while you get used to it
if like the first time having to
take a drug test in front of someone
it's weird
like yeah they're inspecting you they
have to look mostly yeah making sure
it's not rubber
and uh and then i mean now it's like i
don't even break conversation
it's like it happens so often every
competition out of competition
you get to know the guy that's like in
your region for drug testing
did crossfit always have drug testing i
i don't know i don't know if enough
about the history i think it's newer
um but yeah with the crossfit drug
testing it's
i remember the first time i got drug
testing when i first got on the sport i
was like
i think these guys are doping like i
don't believe it
and i didn't know about the drug testing
protocols and then
i had to sign up for it because i was
doing well enough in the sport and then
i get a phone call
of like hey this is so and so from the
drug testing where
your name got pulled and i was i was
honestly excited because i'm like oh
sweet they do regulate this
this is great so i was like yeah i'm at
the address that i listed
come on in door's unlocked and he's like
oh no no we'll be there tomorrow
i was like what i'm like you're called
you're giving me a day's notice
i don't like that at all like you can
flush your system out in a day right
a lot of things i have to assume that if
if you know what you're doing you have a
plan b like you have to assume
that you're gonna get tested at some
point right how can they i know that the
usada stopped allowing people to use ivs
because one of the things they said
about ivs is that it allows you to flush
your system out
you can test negatives i never knew the
reasoning i remember
it was coming up like those iv bars that
like they just
jam-packed it full of vitamins and
whatever like these super doses and it's
like started as like a hangover cure
right
right um and i remember that was getting
pitched like other people around me were
doing them
and they're like you should do this and
i'm like all right my livelihood depends
on
not breaking the rules so i'm like and
i'm contacting people
at crossfit like hey is this allowed and
it's like right there in the rulebook of
like no ivs over
50 milliliters or something equivalent
to like a tablespoon or two tablespoons
so i was like okay that's not allowed
not doing that but yeah
i mean so you can't even do iv vitamin
trips
interesting yeah but you can do some ivs
like i said no ivs i think if it's a
medical emergency so like if you're
super dehydrated yeah so like if you're
in trouble and like getting hospitalized
or
like there's a a need for it
i think it's allowed catch new episodes
of the joe rogan experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience